يكشف ان الهند وباكستان اقتربت من حرب
النوويه الازهار يطالب في بيان بمقاطعه
المنتجات الهولنديه والسويديه الجيش
الروسيه يفرض على جنوده حلقه اللحم وقدره
يرد هذه الاخبار وغيرها منقولها لكم من
قناه العربيه اهلا بكم
قوله ان الهند وباكستان اقتربت من اندلاع
الحرب النوويه في 2019 وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه السابق اوضح ان هذا الامر حدث
ان تلهي ضربات ضد مسلحين في باكستان في
اعقابه هجوم على القوات الهنديه في كاشمير
قائلا انه ليس ابدا تلك الليله عندما
اخبره مسؤول هندي هاتيا انه يعتقد لان
الباكستانيين بداوا في تجهيزه اسلحتها من
نوويه لتوجيه ضربه واضافهم فيه ان مسؤولين
امريكيين اجره عاجله مع مسؤولين بلدين
لاقناعي كل طرفا بان الاخره لا يستعد لحرب
النوويه
احتجاجا على حادثه حرق وتمزيق نسختين من
المصحف في السويد وهولندا طالبه مؤسسه
الازهر الشعوب العربيه والاسلاميه بمقاطعه
منتجات الدولتين الازهر قال في بيان نشر
على صفحته بفيسبوك انه يطالب الشعوب
العربيه والاسلاميه بمقاطعه كل المنتجات
السويديه والهولنديه واتخاذ موقفا قويا
موحد نصره لكتاب الله مضيفا ان المقاطعه
تعد ردا مناسبا لحكمتي هاتين الدولتين في
اساءتهما الى مليار ونصف المليار مسلم
والتمادي في حمايه الجرائم الدنيئه
والبربريه وكذا الازهر ضروره الالتزام
لهذه المقاطعه
في قرار اثر ضجه وسخريه وسعتين امر القائد
العام للقوات الروسيه فاليري جرسيموف جنود
بتحسين انضباطهم اليومي صحيفه ادي تايمز
او راحت في تقرير لها ان هذه التعليمات
الجديده شملت فرض الزي الموحد وقصات الشعر
الموحده على الجنود اضافه الى حلاقه
اللحيه او الذقن وفي تعليقها على هذا
القرار وصف رئيس مجموعه بعدنر القتاليه
قاده الجيش الروسي بانه مجموعه من
المهرجين الذين يسعون لاطفاء بريقا على
الجيش في معتبر الزعيم الشيشاني رمضان هذا
الامر بانه اهانه لقواتهم المسلمه
بعد ما وجدت الغلاء التي شهدتها مصر خلال
الفتره الماضيه خصوصا في اسعار الدواجن
والبيض ضجه السوشيال ميديا بالحديث عن
البيض المخصب الذي انتشر بالاسواق مؤخرا
ومدى صلاحيته للاستخدام ولتوضيح الامر
اكاد مسؤولون في الاتحاد العام المصري
لمنتج الدواجن ان هذا نوع من البيض صالح
للاستخدام العام للمواطنين وغير مقلق على
صحتهم مشيرين في تصريحات سابقه الى ان
البيضه المخصب عباره عن مشروع كتكوت لكنه
لم يكتمل كما شددوا على انه لا يؤثر على
الصحه العامه طالما لم يدخل الى مرحله
الماكينه
[موسيقى]
وفي خبرنا الاخير اعلنت الشرطه الامريكيه
ان كلبا اطلق النار وقتل رجلا بعدما داس
الحيوان على زناد سلاح عن طريق الخطا
اثناء رحله صيد السلطات في ولايتك عن ساس
اوضحت ان الكلب الذي كان جالسا في المقعد
الخلفي لشاحنه صغيره داس على بندقيه ملك
الشاحنه الذي كان جالسا في المقعد
الاماميه ما تسبب في وفاته متاثرا بجراحه
في مكان الحادث في معالجه الشرطه في بيان
المنفصل ان التحقيق جارا لكنها تحقيق
الاولي يظهر انه حادث متعلق بالصيد لا
اكثر
[موسيقى]